Okay, in this last section, we're actually going to go through the steps and the tools
that we need for lens distortion mapping, and then we're going to complete this course
by finishing with our actual lens distortion calibration.
So as we get started with lens distortion mapping, the lens distortion requires the
use of a CG checkerboard and matching physical checkerboard that is printed and mounted on
a rigid surface to hold in view of the production camera.
Let's take a look at what we've actually got up on our stage.
This is printed on a rigid sign.
It's actually aluminum with the black checkers and white checkers mapped on it.
We created this using Adobe Illustrator, but you can also use programs such as Inkscape,
Vectornator, or Vector when creating your physical checkerboard.
I need to ensure the exact accurate measurements of your checkerboard squares in centimeters
matches what we're going to build inside the engine.
Now if I jump back to my slides, you're probably wondering why the checkerboard?
Well that's because lens distortion is calculated or mapped using the Quadrant Intersection
Points or quips in the physical checkerboard pattern.
One thing you want to note here is the quips used for distortion mapping and calculation
are the literal intersection points of each four square quadrant section as set by your
corner rows and corner columns when creating your CG checkerboard asset and matching that
to the physical checkerboard.
So let's just jump right into the engine and get started building our checkerboard here.
So if we take a look in the engine, we're going to first want to have a folder for our
materials that we're going to need for our checkerboard itself.
So let's go ahead and start with our folder.
First I'm going to call this new folder checkerboard because that's what we are building.
Now we can have multiple checkerboards.
The one that we're going to build is a four and a half centimeter checkerboard with seven
corner rows and number corner columns are 11.
To find and build our checkerboard, you just move over to our place actors, which is a
hidden up in the upper left hand corner of our tab.
And then go ahead and move over to our virtual production tab and just drag your checkerboard
in here.
Now before I do that, I want to point out that I am in my current level for my NBC.
This is the NBC sub level located in my persistent level.
And my checkerboard is going to need to live in my track offset actor inside my end display
asset.
So that has to live inside the NBC level itself.
So again, let's go up to our place actors and just go ahead and drag my checkerboard
in and that should make sure that my checkerboard is living here in my NBC level.
So let's go ahead and rename that checkerboard so that we have cam calibration checker 01.
Now with that named, we are going to need to make some adjustments to our checkerboard.
If I look in my viewport at my checkerboard, there's not really anything that's visible
here yet.
That's because the checkerboard itself is quite small.
So to adjust that, we're going to move over into our details panel with my checkerboard
selected.
I'm going to move down here to the calibration tab.
It's right below our transform tab.
And I'm going to skip my calibration points because these are automatically generated
for me.
And I'm going to go ahead and change my corner rows and corner columns.
As I mentioned before, I need seven corner rows and 11 corner columns.
And then for my thickness, I'm going to go ahead and leave that as it is.
And my square side length, let's change that to 4.5 centimeters.
Now we are going to need some materials to make that show up.
Right now there's no materials, so we need to build those.
That's going to take place inside our checkerboard folder.
So go ahead and open that up and then right click to create our first material.
Now this first material we're going to call M underscore checker and call this BLK for
black.
And for that, I'm going to go ahead and open this one right away.
And I'm going to hold down the hotkey three and then just click in my space.
That's going to give me my vector three constant.
And from here, I'm going to connect that right into my base color.
Now it's going to be a little bit shiny.
So from here, I'm going to need another constant.
So let's just go ahead and right click and type in constant.
And it only works if you spell it correctly.
So constant.
And then I'm going to change that value to 0.1 so that I have some specularity, but not
completely.
And then let's connect that to our specular.
And then let's go ahead and hit apply and save.
And that's going to give me my first checker.
Now from here, I am going to close that window, jump back into the engine and to make my life
a little bit easier.
I'm just going to go ahead and duplicate this.
So you could just build this again, but instead I'm going to go ahead and duplicate it.
And then I'm going to change the BLK at the end to COL color.
And I'm going to do that because that is going to give me the option of having a new color.
And if I just go right in here, I can quickly make that adjustment by selecting my color
wheel and moving on up to the color that I want and make this nice and bright pink color
here for me to use.
And I want this pink color because I want to be able to differentiate between the white
checkers that are on the physical checker board and the CG checkers that we're going
to get on our CG checker board.
And you'll understand that once we actually do our calibration, because we'll be able
to transparently view a properly calibrated checker board.
So let's go ahead and apply and save this change as well.
And then once that's saved, we'll see our checker board itself.
Now my checker board isn't quite showing up and that's because I haven't assigned the
colors just yet.
One thing to note is that I want to make sure that the top left corner of my physical checker
board is my odd cube material color.
And my odd cube material color is actually going to be my black material.
So let's go ahead and connect that black material in just by dragging it into my odd cube material
and take my color and move that into my even cube material color.
And that's going to give me the colors for my actual checker board.
Now as I zoom in a little bit, you can kind of see my checker board showing up here.
I want to move this a little bit closer so that it's visible here.
That way I can kind of move this around and you can see what's going to happen here as
it moves.
So this gives me my physical checker board.
And again, this has to actually live underneath my OptiTrack offset actor.
So let's put that into place.
And now you can see that's giving us a lot more location information.
Let's go ahead and zero out that value.
And that's going to zero that out on the floor.
And let's zero out our rotation and then let's move that up.
Now you can see that this is going to appear on the screen, but it's not going to align
because of its position.
Now let's just move that out of the way because we don't want that to show up in my calibration.
And as we're getting ready for calibration itself, let's move on over to our calibration
folder and into our lens file folder.
Now if I jump back into my slides really quick, I just want to point out that there are some
things that we need to note as a difference between Unreal Engine 5.03 and Unreal Engine
5.1.
OK, so in our lens distortion mapping, we now need to apply our lens to the tracked camera.
In 5.0, typically as you go through here, you're going to find that there is a lens file component
that isn't necessarily needed to be added in order to select our lens file.
In order to select that, follow the same rules for 5.0.
Scroll down, expand your camera roll dropdown in your details panel.
Go ahead and then expand the lens file picker.
Select your lens file, which is the LF Zeiss 25 millimeter in our case, and then double
click to reopen that lens file asset.
Now in 5.1, it's a little different here.
You're going to need both a lens component attached to your camera and a live link component
controller for our Fizz data.
You're also going to need to make sure that your virtual subject is virtual.
Don't rename it.
That way it's going to connect the correct virtual subject to that as well in 5.1.
So as a point out here in my slides, you can see that there is a lens black magic Zeiss
in here.
If we jump on over to the engine, you will see that we have this selected as well.
And as I'm looking through the engine, and if I scroll up here, the very first thing
that's selected is my lens file Zeiss 25 millimeter P3.
If I skip down to my Zeiss Fizz here, you can see that I've got my subject representation
as virtual.
This is my virtual subject and my subject itself is a virtual subject.
That virtual subject is actually using this blueprint class, the blueprint live link virtual
subject black magic Zeiss.
And if I switch over to my live link here, you can see if I select my virtual subject,
I've got it set where they focus iris and zoom that is set at 25 millimeters.
If I go back to my details panel and scroll down just a little bit under the camera roll
as we have expanded, we can now see that my lens file is connected here in my LF Zeiss
25 millimeter P3.
That is the same lens file that we are using here.
So I can go ahead and double click that.
And that will actually launch my lens file.
Now you can see here that I've got my lens files, my track camera and my lens component
is the lens black magic Zeiss.
My raw fizz input is actually coming from my live link virtual subject.
And I'm just going to move this down and kind of resize this a little bit so you can see
what's happening.
And as you can see here, if I move over to my live link section, I've got a 25 millimeter
zoom here and it matches my raw fizz input.
If I change that information, I'm going to change that to 35 millimeter.
And you can see that changes my lens and my view as well and the zoom information here
at 35.
Now because we're at a fixed lens with 25 millimeter, we want to make sure that that
is set correctly at 25 millimeter.
And then I can actually adjust my focus and iris controls as well.
So as I start to update this for my camera and my zoom, I can go ahead and pull that
information and kind of figure out how far we are away from our subject and make those
updates as well.
Now as I'm in my lens information and my lens information is correct, again, my transparency
allows me to switch between these two so I can see what is a full and transparent here.
And now I can go ahead and just kind of leave that at 0.5.
Although it's a lot easier to work with if I set this transparency to zero as we are
ready to capture images through our lens distortion.
So let's kind of move over to our lens distortion tab and let's make sure that we are correct
in here as well.
And I've got my camera, which again is my black magic's ice, make sure that's selected.
My media source is correct so you can see I'm coming through my Aja device and I've
got an overlay.
This is really for my crosshair.
I'm not going to make much use of this.
And then for my lens distortion algorithm, I want to make sure I choose my lens distortion
checker board that we've created and that we're using the actual camera calibration
checker that exists in here as well.
Now I also want to show a coverage overlay and show detection so that I can get some
visual feedback in here.
Now to get started, all I got to do right now is just click on the first image.
And as you can see, I get feedback that shows me that I've got all of my quips showing up
in here so they're calibrated correctly.
It shows me my calibration in a feedback image.
And if I close this image, you can see that I've got my index showing up here as well.
Okay, so as we're getting ready to do our calibration, let's take a quick look at some
of the tools in the real world that we're actually going to be using.
If I first look up at my checker board, which you can see through the camera itself, the
checker board is on a stand and is our first image.
But now we want to take a look over at our camera because we want to be able to measure
specifically what our camera's position and make adjustments to our FIS data in the engine
here as well.
Now, I am going to be using a laser measuring tool here.
So you can see this is my Bosch professional measuring tool.
And if I look at the top of my camera here, there is a little mark.
This is going to mark and show where my sensor's position is actually located.
So inside my camera, this is where my camera sensor is located.
Now if I put my Bosch right up against this, so it's kind of lined up in the same position
and just push this button, you can see a little laser kind of show up on the sensor
itself.
And if I look down here and just press the button one more time, that's going to give
me a distance of about six feet, three inches from the camera's sensor all the way to the
wall.
As you can see here, that's six, three.
Now I want to make the adjustment here on my lens.
So if I kind of come back around and Sean joins me over here, I need to make the adjustment
from 4.6 feet to a little bit over six feet here.
So now I'm all set up in that position.
Now my T stop here, we are set to four, but I want to open this up as high as I can to
get it not as much light in as possible.
So I'm going to set this as 2.1.
So now these two things are set on my camera and I'm ready to go back into the engine.
And from there, I'm going to need to make some adjustments to my Fizz data that matches
that information.
Now to make that adjustment, let's just go ahead and pull this aside a little bit.
And I'm going to go ahead and change my focus, which is my focus distance to 190.5.
And my iris was set at my T stop of 2.1.
So I'm going to make that change as well.
And you'll notice those changes get adjusted here inside my Fizz data.
Now with that ready to go, I do need to actually do my images over again.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit clear all on this.
So first let's click on this.
Here's my first image.
This is just going to give me a nice central image.
And while that's set, let's have Sean go ahead and move that up into the upper left hand
corner.
And you'll notice there's an overlay.
So my quips are calibrated and collected and they stay on screen.
You want to make sure that this fills the frame, but doesn't get too high.
And it gets closer to the edge if you can right in here.
Now it doesn't need to be too high on the top.
It just needs to fill in the top corner here.
And the reason for that is so as we move over, this black part is actually going to obscure
it and may cause a error here.
Now to continue our calibration collection of images, we can go ahead and collect this
image.
And again, I'm not going to keep you through all of these.
We'll finish this up and you'll see this in another section.
So expect a little bit of a jump.
Okay, so now that we finished our distortion mapping collection, you'll notice here that
we have an index series of images.
Now I have 35 images from my collection right here.
And you can see as I scrub through them that Sean moved his way from left to right in different
various locations and then created a couple of images that were from various angles.
This is going to allow us some distortion and kind of see how the camera lens is going
to read some of that information.
Now once that's done, you just go ahead and apply our calibration data.
And to do that, we're going to go down to the bottom here and add to lens distortion
calibration.
Now we are going to get an RMS reprojection error and we are going to want a number that
is below 0.1 or better.
Right now we have an RMS number of 0.51.
That's actually still pretty good and it's going to give us a fairly decent set to work
from.
Now this is our first calibration point.
So if I go ahead and hit OK to apply that, you can see everything is going to disappear
and we're going to go into our lens file panel.
And if I look at my focus and my iris, you're going to see that I've got a specific point
here at a focus of 190.5.
That's going to give me my first point at my zoom and calibration and it's going to
allow me to kind of create some other points in here.
Now to create additional points, I'm going to make the adjustments in our FIS data to
a new focal length.
So we would change our iris here.
You'll notice it's going to get a little bit darker in what you're seeing in here.
I'm going to change my T stop and I'm going to put that all the way as dark as I can at
22 and you can see how dark that is.
Now, probably not going to need to be quite that dark.
So I'm going to open this up just a little bit.
Let's go to 11 so we can still see things that's in here.
But realistically, we'll probably want to push this to the extremes, the farthest distance
that we're going to see in here.
And then we want to actually create a new distance length as well.
So if I go in here and make the adjustment, we want to get a little bit closer.
So we would create another set with Sean and we'd move this up to about three feet.
So we're at three three right now and we're pretty much filling the frame.
Since we don't want to go quite that far, we're actually going to adjust our lens to
three three in here and that way we can kind of come on back and we're going to make the
adjustment inside our FIS data to match that.
So as I mentioned, we changed our iris from 2.1 to 11 and we changed our focus distance
from six feet, three to three feet, three.
And that's about 99 centimeters.
So with that set, we can go ahead and collect our first image.
So let's have Sean move that in the upper left hand corner and we're ready to grab that first image.
Now it's really dark, but it's still a good image.
And I want Sean to move around the four corners here so that we can get these four images in here.
And we can stop right there.
And now let's lower it down and let's move back to the other corner.
Okay, now these were four points.
Typically you want to have no fewer than eight to 10 points.
So for this, I would have Sean move this so it's dead center, which is good right there.
And then he can pull the checkerboard that we have mounted on a specifically set up mount.
And we can move this around to create some specific angles on this and rotate that a little bit.
There we go.
A little bit turn your angle just a little bit less.
So everything fits because it's going to look for the corner points that they're not all in
there. It's not going to show up.
Okay, so let's rotate again.
Okay, and let's add another rotation on the other side.
And let's rotate it the opposite direction.
Okay, and that's going to give us eight images, which is the bare minimum here.
So with that done, I'm going to have Sean just go ahead and put that back in a place.
And you're going to see me actually add this to my lens distortion calibration.
This is my RMS projection error is at point two now.
So it's a lot smaller with fewer images, which is actually pretty good.
So we're going to hit OK.
And as we go over to our lens file, you can see now that a new distortion point.
So this is my distortion map and my distortion map is starting to work.
Now let's jump back to our slide so that you have this information available to you to look at.
And as we walk through, I want to point out that, yes, we created a couple of images
and it looks just like this.
And we added that to our last section.
Now, as I mentioned, there is an RMS error that you're actually going to look for.
And we need to make sure that our calibrator is actually correct.
So the last section that we need to do is to go back and apply this to our calibrator.
So if I go ahead and jump back in the engine again and look at my calibration steps,
there is a couple of other options that are in here.
So to get this to work, the distortion parameters need to update here in our lens editor.
And we need to verify our lens distortion with our nodal offset tab.
So let's move over to our nodal offset tab and we're going to need to bring all that
information into our section.
So with the nodal point offset selection, we want to go and change our offset points method to our checkerboard.
I want to choose the checkerboard that we are actually using and it is going to have multiple values.
Now to get this to work, all we got to do is click into our viewport and that's going to add in our corner data.
Now all I got to do on this is hit apply to calibrator and this will apply that to my lens distortion map.
And you can see I've got my focal length adjustments that are in here,
but I didn't get any focus distance or aperture because we're going to control that on our own and we have a fixed lens on here.
But what I did get was my distortion parameters.
So you can see I've got my distortion parameters that are in here and now we want to be able to see whether or not this is actually going to work.
So if I scrub through here and I adjust my transparency, you can see that my checkerboard is now filled in with my pink checkers.
This tells me visually that my lens distortion mapping is accurate.
If my CG overlay matches my video feed, then my calculations here are visually confirmed.
Again, scrubbing through here, you can see how these are actually lining up correctly.
Now we did a short quick calibration with just two points.
So there is a little bit of fuzziness in here, but this is still pretty good.
So with that in mind, the next step is to go on and do our nodal point calibration from this point.